بعد سته ايام من الاشتباكات المسلحه
والعمليات العسكريه بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع كيف تبدو الاوضاع الرهينه داخل
مدينه مروي نحن هنا لنجيب على هذا التساؤل
كان في اغلب الناس رحلوا من المنطقه مشوش
شريك
الحمد لله الليله من الصباح النصر
ورجعوا للترتيبات والحاجاتهم للعيد وربنا
يطمن الناس اكثر واكثر ان شاء الله يا رب
الحمد لله وسع الحيوان يستقر الحمد لله
احنا ناشد عن القوات المسلحه
والدعم السريع
يرجع لصوت العقل ويحفظ دماء الشعب
السوداني الحمد لله عمنا البلد امنه
والناس كلهم يعني في شغل معادل هنا يومين
ثلاثه الحمد لله رب العالمين نحن رسالتنا
انه ربنا يصلح ذات البين اي ناس مختلفين
مع بعض يسووا امور يسووا مع بعض يتفقوا
عشان ما يضرروا المواطن المواطنين دول ناس
تعبانين الناس عايشين عيشه صعبه جدا جدا
يقول الحمد لله على السلامه والهم يستتبوا
وربنا يقوي جيشنا ويدينا الصحه والعافيه
وكل سنه وانتم طيبين
الحيه عاده الحياه الحمد لله وما في عوجه
والحمد لله وكل
خير الاشتباكات الاخيره والعمليات
العسكريه كانت فقط في محيط مطار مروي
والقاعده العسكريه اما محليه مروي والقرى
التي تحيط بها فقد كانت بعيده عن هذه
الاشتباكات ويبدو ان حاله الهدوء تسيطر
على المكان داخل هذه المحليه نزار
البغداوي لقناتي العربيه والحدث من داخل
محليه مروي الولايه الشماليه
اعطي
المزيد قياد والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط على
زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات